[Music]
[Applause]
all right so I see some married people
here I was married I was married for 49
years okay seven but you know whatever
didn't work anyway the thing is probably
we had we were married for seven years
it didn't have kids so you have to have
kids once you're married you do because
you need the distraction you know you
need something else to focus on cuz if
you don't you have too much time to
focus on why you can't stand each other
little things will just start getting
all your nerves I'll find myself just
looking at no so Tigers going look at
him every time we eat he has to chew
chew and stuff I don't imagine we would
date and what is this you chewing and
that blinking what is that blink blink
blink what you up will you sleep make up
your mind what is that yeah so my
parents they're all upset they are
because they've been together over 40
years no divorce you know so they don't
understand this thing you know my
mother's like divorced
oh it's just that easy huh things get a
little hard a little rough you just
throw in the towel like that what's the
problem our gonna fight and that's it
that's a bunch of bull let me tell you
some your father and I had a shootout
okay here sure where I shot you no you
see that's lon right there he knew he
was wrong
I shot him you move on
relationships are hard yeah they just
how I feel sorry you know I feel sorry
for guys cuz where did we get nuts we do
we get so nutty you know we overanalyze
everything right yeah guy tell us
something we turn around to mean
something else yeah if a guy tell us oh
you know I think we should see other
people yeah we'll go oh you know what it
is he's falling in love with me
that's what it is my love is so
overwhelming that he feels like he has
to remove himself from this love because
he wants to live the rest of his life
with me and he just that's what it is
it's just a fit no it's not he told you
what it means is hey I need to see other
people in other words I'm tired of
having sex with you I would like to have
sex with someone else I suggest you do
the same
sex is very important to men it is I
think it's the most important thing
I mean look they found a cure for
impotence they discovered viagra right
and I don't think this was some new
search you know they that's what Sergent
been going on for years
all right that's been way ahead of heart
disease cancer you know smallpox okay
anything that didn't cure they just
stumbled across it on their way trying
to find viagra hey you know I think this
is my cute tuberculosis okay we'll get
that out of here doing a damn thing for
my penis come on tell the guy okay the
only side effect of Viagra is that it
could kill you hmm kill me will help my
penis I'll take my chances
I mean easy to see why men enjoy sex I
mean just biologically right I mean even
see you know no matter what men are
always gonna complete the act right no
matter what they're gonna complete no
matter how bad the sex is they're always
going to complete the act it doesn't
work like that for us does it ladies no
we got to get midstream before we figure
out oh this is not gonna happen not
happening yeah that's what I told guys
if you know how to satisfy your woman
stick with that all right I tell it got
a minute hey what you did that was good
jack that damn no remember that
seriously stick with that okay no no
same plan stick with that don't get
fancy I'll be taking some new route that
you don't know anything about because
you're gonna get lost and just like a
man you're not gonna stop and ask for
directions
you just gonna keep going till you run
out of gas
leaving me stranded in the middle of
nowhere
got to get myself home
great Thank You Wanda close everybody
let's take a break